[Musique]
je crois que beaucoup de gens ont perdu
dieu que nous sommes des prédateurs et
que pendant longtemps nous avons vécu de
la chasse et de la cueillette
nous avons deux yeux pour regarder
devant nous nous sommes faits pour
apporter de la viande
c'est donc ici que je trouve mon
supermarché
[Musique]
enfant j'ai toujours su que je voulais
travailler et vivre à la ferme
et ça même à l'époque où il y avait très
peu de femmes qu'il faisait
mais les hommes faisait les travaux
d'extérieur et les femmes étaient
cantonnés aux ménages et à la cuisine
pour nourrir leur somme rien d'autre
cette vie là c'était pas pour moi
[Musique]
le premier boulot que j'ai eue c'était
dans une fabrique de canettes avec un
pinceau je devais rabattre les petits
bouts de ferraille sur le côté de la
canette pour qu'un autre ouvrier puisque
les souder ensuite je faisais ça 11
heures par jour ce qui m'a fait me dire
que j'allais pas passer le reste de ma
vie dans une usine
c'est vers l'âge de 12 ans je crois que
j'ai acheté mon premier cochon et une
truie que j'appelais madame la [__]
et ça fait maintenant 27 ans que je suis
éleveur
alors croyez moi c'est dur pour un gars
qui s'occupe de ces bêtes tous les jours
h 24 de s'entendre dire qu'il fait pas
comme il faudrait
[Musique]
puis plus loin que je me souvienne j'ai
toujours chasser notre famille était
plutôt pauvre on mangeait pas souvent de
la viande alors c'était le boulot des
gosses d'en rapporter pour toute la
famille c'est vers l'âge de 8 ans que
j'ai commencé à chasser les lapins etc
on a commencé à manger ce qu'on prenait
à la chasse j'ai grandi à la ville par
la campagne on avait des bmx pour nous
échapper de la ville et à les chasser
les lapins j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui les
gamins pourrez toujours aller chasser
les lapins mais ils ont d'autres façons
de s'amuser comme les ipad et
ordinateurs dieu sait quoi encore comme
distraction
moi quand j'étais môme j'avais rien
alors fallait bien que je trouve des
idées pour m'amuser
on n'achète jamais de la viande toutes
celles qu'on consomme vient de la forêt
on peut dire que c'est la loi de la
nature
les prédateurs et les carnivores sont
destinés à manger de la viande
j'imagine qu'on pourrait peut-être
chasse et d'une façon qui serait plus
éthique et on en tirait plus de plaisir
on s'est contenté de faire un abri et de
mettre un toit déçu puis on à élever des
animaux dans ce genre d'environnement
allez va par là
c'est vraiment formidable chacune de ses
fruits va produire plus de deux tonnes
de viande chaque année on les met dans
ces espèces de cages et on amène le
verra devant elle c'est un peu comme un
peep-show si elles sont en chaleur ça
les stimule et elles sont partantes pour
la suite elles vont pas essayer de
s'échapper
elles attendent le mal il nous reste
plus qu'à imiter les mouvements du mâle
en s'asseyant sur leur dos on s'assied
sur elle et on fait les mêmes mouvements
que le verra on fait pareil on essaie de
faire les mêmes mouvements
il faut que la femelle soit heureuse
sinon je pourrai pas lui introduire la
semence car c'est elle qu'il aspire en
quelque sorte c'est pour ça que je la
stimule avec le mal à côté je m'assis
sur elle comme comme quand le mâle lui g
dessus et c'est ce qui lui permet de se
contracter et d'aspirer la semence du
sachet
avec mon associé nigel on a acheté ici
en 1996
ça fait un peu plus de vingt ans on
possède trois grandes étendues terrain
et on a environ 1500 brebis et moutons
reproducteurs ont fait le commerce
d'animaux précoce on vend environ entre
3000 et 5000 animaux pendant la période
estivale
au printemps je fais environ 800
agnelages quand on a commencé à
travailler ici nos à nyon était destinée
au marché britannique pour noël et
depuis quelques années on travaille avec
la france et les etats-unis mais disons
que le gros de nos ventes est destiné au
marché européen pour noël comme la
nouvelle zélande n'a pas assez de
population qui sont sommés ce qu'on
produit ici on est obligés de vendre à
l'étranger
on pourrait pas vivre de notre travail
si on ne faisait pas ça il arrive bien
sûr qu'on perde des bêtes c'est la vie
je dirais
j'étais professeur dans un collège
j'enseignais les mathématiques les
sciences la physique l'électronique et
l'éducation religieuse
vous adorez ce métier puis on est arrivé
ici il est tombé amoureux de la maison
et des alentours
c'était un ancien élevage de poulets
tous les poulaillers était encore là
alors on s'est demandé ce qu'on allait
faire avec tous ces abris qui à
l'origine était destiné au poulet est la
seule réponse possible c'était de faire
un élevage de poulets et aujourd'hui on
a environ dix neuf mille poulet mais
notre client principal en veut de plus
en plus et petit à petit le nombre
augmente et on a plus suffisamment de
place pour les élever alors on fait
appel à des personnes de la campagne
qu'il le faut pour nous pour un élevage
de volailles je dirais que ce n'est pas
très grand ici tu pourrais m'aider en
soulevant par le bas ils ont été mis
dans ses caisses à 2 heures du matin à
hamilton
ils vont rester chez nous environ six
semaines
puis après ils seront préparés et
finiront sous un film alimentaire
[Musique]
ça me pose aucun problème de dire à mes
enfants que la viande qu'il mange vient
de la nature mais j'hésite un peu plus à
leur parler de ce qui se passe dans les
élevages
je ne suis pas sûr des enfants soient
obligés de savoir comment ça fonctionne
dans les abattoirs
il faut qu'ils en savent suffisamment
afin de pouvoir faire leur choix après
mais je suis pas certain qu'on soit
forcé de leur dire tiens regarde si
poulet regarde ses cochons j'ai souvent
un peu de mal avec les gens qui achètent
de la viande parce que souvent ils se
rendent pas compte de tout ce qui se
passe dans la chaîne alimentaire pour
que la viande passe de la ferme à leur
assiette
ils se rendent pas compte non plus de ce
qui se produit pour un animal sauvage
quand il va de la nature jusqu'à votre
assiette
c'est un processus très long et très
compliqué pour un animal élevé pour ça
alors que c'est un processus beaucoup
plus simple pour un animal sauvage
je critique pas les gens je pense
seulement qu'ils ont besoin d'être
informés
même si je suis contre l'élevage en cage
ça m'empêche pas d'acheter et de manger
du bacon c'est ce qu'on appelle deux
poids deux mesures n'ont de nombreuses
personnes deviennent végétarienne
lorsque elle supporte pas qu'on tue des
animaux et du coup elles deviennent
végétarienne et elles sont également
contre la chasse ce sont des anti
chasseurs pur et dur parce qu'ils savent
pas que la chasse c'est un moyen plutôt
éthique d'obtenir de la viande
il est vrai qu'on tue des animaux et
qu'on les emporte après et qu'à cause de
nous ils ne vivent pas paisiblement dans
la nature et ne crèvent pas de faim
quand ils sont vieux juste sans tuer
quand ils sont jeunes et ensuite ils
sont mangés et mais je crois que le
choix
enfin le moment charnière où il passe du
stade de carnivore à celui de
végétariens c'est quand ils voient
comment les poulets sont traités comment
les cochons sont traités comment le
bétail est traitée et les moutons aussi
si à ce moment là qu'ils se disent ça
suffit
je mangerai plus de viande je vais
devenir végétarien alors que je crois
que s'ils étaient informés des
conditions dans lesquelles se passent la
chasse il dirait désormais on va manger
que de la viande qu'on a chassé et pas
de la viande d'élevage
j'entends une brebis qui est en train de
brailler
j'ai bien l'impression que ça signifie
qu'elle va bientôt mettre bas
débrouillarde comme nana très
débrouillarde
je me souviendrai toujours de la fois où
j'ai entendu cette voiture freiné je me
suis demandé ce qui se passait alors je
les ai suivis pendant environ un
kilomètre et quand ils se sont arrêtés
et j'ai cru que c'est un couple qui se
disputaient parce qu'elle elle voulait
descendre de la voiture et lui
l'empêcher de sortir il disait appelé
une ambulance de cuillère à pot gelé d
accoucher et sortir le gamin et je leur
ai dit laisser tomber l'ambulance lui il
voulait faire comme on voit à la télé
ils voulaient des serviettes de l'eau
chaude mais moi j'ai pas besoin de tout
ça je leur ai dit que c'est comme avec
les agneaux
si vous vous approchez vous pourrez voir
qu'il y a eu un petit problème il ya une
grosse heure qui s'est développée sur la
phase de l'animal ainsi que sur ses
pattes
la brebis a eu des difficultés à
l'expulser à cause des épaules il aurait
fallu que je sois là avant pour tirer
sur les épaules de l'agneau
il y a des jours où on a une naissance
et puis d'autres jours on en a pas et le
lendemain il y en a à nouveau deux ou
trois vers la fin de la gestation plus
la nuit où va être gros plus la mise bas
va être difficile évidemment quand ce
sont des sièges il faut les aider à
mettre bas tout ce qu'on peut apercevoir
c'est un petit bout de queue et les pas
de plier comme ça alors là ce qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut tirer dessus les
mettre dans cette position le pire des
scénarios faire quand il nous arrive ça
nigel a dit que la tête et est sorti
mais il y avait juste son museau qui
pointe et si la tête avait été sorti en
même temps que les pattes ça aurait
causé un gonflement et c'est là que
j'aurais dû mettre la main à l'intérieur
pour tenter d'attraper les pâtes et les
sortir tandis que là c'est une situation
beaucoup plus simple elle n'a pas pu
l'expulser parce que ce sont juste les
épaules qui ont coincé au moment de
sortir les c'est tout
allez va l'intérieur tourne tourne
tourne tourne
je crois que les animaux nous font
confiance
alors du coup ils n'obéissent assez
facilement allez on les conduit ici cinq
jours avant qu'elle mette bas comme ça
elles peuvent s'installer
confortablement
elles savent qu'elles sont dans un
endroit sûr et que tout va bien se
passer
nous tout ce qu'on fait c'est un peu
comme une mère qui va à l'hôpital pour
accoucher
si je me réfère à mon épouse nous avons
trois enfants et pour le premier je sais
qu'elle était impatiente de rentrer à la
maison pour le deuxième elle a apprécié
de rester un peu plus car la sage femme
pouvait les prendre le petit de temps en
temps et comme ça elle pouvait se
reposer et être au calme et elle n'avait
pas à s'inquiéter des choses de la vie
courante comme ça elle avait juste à se
préoccuper de son nouveau-né et pour son
troisième accouchement elle était super
content d'être à la maternité
il n'était pas du tout impatient de
revenir à la maison on a pris exemple
sur les humains avec les truies et on
s'est dit qu'ici leur seule
préoccupation serait de s'occuper de
leurs petits
allez vas-y ma belle bonjour le monde
regardez-moi ça y est je suis sorti je
vais ouvrir les yeux et chouette non ce
qui serait bien c'est que chaque femelle
est très petit et qu'on réussisse à en
nourrir une douzaine ça m'irait bien ça
me rappelle encore quelle peu de temps
après mon installation
quand on en avait dix dans une semaine
on trouvait que c'était bien aujourd'hui
avec juste dix ans ferait faillite
pour les animaux ici c'est leur
environnement naturel
alors quelqu'un qui débarquent ici et
qui nous dit c'est pas les conditions
naturelles suis pas d'accord moi je
m'arrête pas aux cages moi ce que je
vois ce sont les petits qui sont
protégés et les maires dont on peut bien
s'occuper de façon individuelle en tant
qu'éleveur je vois tout l'intérêt des
cages et tous les avantages qu'elle
avorte suis vraiment à l'aise pour vous
dire tout ça
les huit fruits qui sont ici ils vont
produire l'équivalent de mille animaux
en viande chaque année nous faisons de
l'élevage sélectif ici quand les truies
en plus de porcelets qu'elles ont deux
mamelles
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on met des petits
as tu étais sur d'autres femelles comme
ça à chacune a plus ou moins le même
nombre de petits à nourrir alors venez
pas me dire qu'on s'occupe pas de nos
animaux c'est parce que mes truies en
pense mais en tout cas elles n'ont pas
l'air d'être trop contrarié par la
manière dont on les traite
moi je vous dise qu'on fait c'est
vraiment pas si mal
venez jeter un oeil à notre incubateur
en fait c'est comme une grosse boule en
bois en premier les oeufs sont déposées
dans cet endroit qui s'appelle le
support et et toutes les deux heures ça
fait ça c'est bon pour les os ça fait du
bien aux poussins on le fait bien chaud
ensuite ils sont transférés après
l'opération de mirage où on s'assure
qu'ils sont fait qu'on aime regarder et
tendez l'oreille c'est plein de vie tout
ça alors qu'il y avait rien n'y a pas si
longtemps
tout est parfait quelle belle vie
nous avons un cheptel reproducteur
nous accueillons 200 poussins chaque
semaine et qui tous les matins nous
ramassons tous les yeux que nous
trouvons au sol honorine tous les
mercredis nous les portons l'incubateur
mettre à neuf à incuber c'est un peu
comme planter une graine et l'arroser
ensuite une fois que la température et
l'hygrométrie sont correctes le
processus commence
c'est un peu comme lorsqu'une poule se
mettent à couver pendant environ une
douzaine de jours ils vont tous éclore
le même jour elle ne commence d'ailleurs
à couver que lorsque le dernier rush
répondu elles ne sont pas aussi idiote
qu'elles en ont l'air
il pleut des poussins le truc marrant
quand on y pense c'est qu'ils
remboursent leur nourriture
puisque grâce à eux on gagne de l'argent
dont ils ont personnes sur leur dos qui
les ennuie on ne s'épanouissent ça a
toujours été ça l'idée vous voulez
augmenter nos revenus pour nous aider à
payer l'emprunt qu'on a souscrit en
achetant la faire parce que la terre est
surcoté on n'a pas assez de revenus pour
rembourser cet emprunt alors qu'elle et
moi on a dû prendre un deuxième boulot
pour financer notre ferme lui il est
toujours chauffeur routier il fait ce
qu'il peut pour nous aider moi j'ai
travaillé dans la police pendant 33 ans
ça m'a aidé à payer la ferme
quand j'étais flics je me levais à 5
heures pour nourrir les votes et ensuite
jallet brancher les clôtures électriques
pour le bétail avait déjà fait une demi
journée de boulot avant de prendre mon
service
parfois je faisais 60 heures par semaine
au poste de police
et il fallait que je fasse aussi tourner
la ferme c'est une façon de vivre qui
est ancré dans les habitudes du monde
rural
c'est comme ça que j'ai été élevé vous
savez j'ai un peu de mal avec les gens
qui travaillent pas et qui après vienne
te dire que c'est juste un boulot que tu
fais histoire de t'occuper elle est
finie l'époque où les gens garder
longtemps le même boulot aujourd'hui il
n'hésite pas en changer leur boulot leur
plaît pas ils se disent fait mettre au
chômage ou va retrouver un autre
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de fils de
fermiers qui veulent pas reprendre la
suite parce qu'ils peuvent gagner plus
en travaillant derrière un ordinateur
que sur une exploitation et il se
salissent pas les mains c'est un travail
manuel et physique et ils veulent plus
faire
[Musique]
les gens ont toujours des idées arrêtées
sur les éleveurs porcins mais ils n'ont
pas les mêmes préjugés sur les éleveurs
de moutons les éleveurs bovins
ça donne pas lieu à des points de vue
aussi extrémistes qu'en ce qui concerne
les éleveurs de porcs nous à cause de
notre boulot on n'est pas invités à des
manifestations alors qu'un avocat un
comptable ou encore un directeur de
banque
on va être invité justement parce qu'il
est avocat comptable ou directeurs de
banques
personne n'a envie de fréquenter un
éleveur de porcs on n'est pas une
profession qui est très recherché à les
pousse toi avance
là on est en manque de semences mais
j'ai encore deux femelles à inséminer
alors va falloir que mais mal travail
ce mal est un peu plus vieux et c'est ce
qu'il a à faire
il n'est pas trop fort en préliminaire
voyez on n'est pas là pour rigoler
il est dedans la société veut qu'on
produise de la viande bon marché
alors on a fait ce qu'on nous a demandé
et plus on produisait et plus la demande
augmente et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet boule de neige
eh bien mon pépère les gens supportent
pas d'attendre le voit bien avec nos
téléphones portables
fini le temps où l'essai des messages
aujourd'hui on veut une réponse
immédiate alors c'est la même chose on
veut avoir la nourriture dont on a envie
tout de suite et on veut que ce soit
comme ça toute l'année alors que je me
rappelle très bien que lorsque j'étais
gamin on discutait pas le fait qu'il y
avait certaines saisons pour avoir la
nourriture quand vous les consommez de
nos jours la nouvelle génération ne
raisonne pas du tout comme ça il ne
pense pas à la saisonnalité des produits
puisque avec la globalisation on peut
tout emporter
si les oranje ne sont pas mûrs en ce
moment en nouvelle zélande on en
importera de californie l'idée qu'on
doit faire sans un produit est
complètement obsolète désormais excuse
moi c'est cruel un les oblige à
s'arrêter
[Musique]
bel et bien à côté là bas
d'un point de vue humain on peut dire
que c'est cruel de les garder comme ça
mais les truies pense pas pareil les
animaux ne nous disent pas et on n'aime
pas être dans ses cages c'est vrai que
du point de vue de l'éleveur
quand on décrit le truc et qu'on le
visualisant paix fectivement se dire
qu'une s et cruel comme traitement elles
peuvent pas bouger là dedans mais si on
se met à la place de l'animal c'est pas
du tout la même chose
les bêtes ont de l'eau de la nourriture
elles sont à l'abri et ça tout au long
de leur vie et c'est tout ce qu'elles
veulent elles sont protégés et tout ça
sans stress et pourtant on essaie de
nous mettre dans la tête que c'est pas
bien
chasser c'est l'exact opposé de faire
ses courses dans un supermarché je pense
la boutique n'est pas toujours
approvisionner en nourriture
celle ci est difficile à trouver c'est
un peu comme une chasse au trésor en
réalité ces saisonniers
ça peut prendre un jour ça peut en
prendre deux avant d'avoir une croix
parfois je pars toute une semaine
c'est là que je vais pouvoir faire le
plein de mon réfrigérateur
aujourd'hui pas de chevreuil à
chevrières non plus apparemment ils sont
pas nombreux sur les bords de la rivière
on est tous dans le printemps et les
chevreuils doivent encore être dans les
hauteurs ils sont pas encore descendu
pour brouter l'herbe alors ça sert à
rien que je me mette en chasse par ce
que j'ai vu aucune empreinte de
chevreuil nulle part dans le coin je
crois qu'il va falloir qu'on grimpe plus
haut dans la montagne vers le sommet si
on veut trouver des animaux il me semble
comme et 400 sont plus en connexion avec
ce qui est autour de moi quand je chasse
c'est une sensation extraordinaire qui
titille l'instinct de chasseur cueilleur
qui résident dans chaque être humain
lorsque vous ralentissez votre allure
tous vos sens se connecte à
l'environnement qui se trouvent autour
de vous c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable
imaginez un animal qui vit ici où il n'y
a aucun bruit à part ceux de la rivière
et de la pluie ces animaux entente où il
voit tout celle inverse des humains qui
se sont déconnectés de la nature parce
qu'il ya tellement de bruits parasites
qui les entoure en permanence
rien que le fait d'être ici dans le bush
c'est un sentiment extraordinaire
je répète souvent à ceux qui sont non
chasseurs et que je mène à la chasse de
ne pas faire de bruit de ce taire et de
murmurer il faut se mettre en mode
silencieux
e
j'ai toujours eu mon franc parler j'ai
toujours fait ce qui me plaisait j'ai
jamais eu peur de rien et c'est tout
j'ai aucune aucune limite
une femme est capable d' absolument tout
faire dans le coin où j'ai grandi je
n'étais entouré que par des garçons
j'étais la seule fille du coup ça m'a
habitué aux bagarres et ouais c'est sûr
que j'étais pas la dernière à me jeter
dans la mêlée et j'avais besoin de
personne pour me défendre je vous le dis
j'ai jamais eu peur de rien vous
comprenez pourquoi est-ce que tu agis
comme ça je repense à ma mère elle
faisait pas de travaux physiques à
l'extérieur c'est ça la génération dans
laquelle j'ai été élevée avant les nanas
n'avait aucune opportunité de faire quoi
que ce soit c'étaient les mecs qui
dirigeait tout est encore 40 ou 50 ans
il n'aurait jamais engagé une femme
comme berger où j'ai été élevé avec
l'idée qu'il fallait avoir de la force
la force comme un mec pour faire les
choses et ben c'est pas vrai c'est à toi
te débrouiller dans la vie
on y est je fais ça comme une femme
les brebis sont plus lourdes que moi
font dans les 80 90 kg ça va être plus
facile comme ça et en plus elle peut pas
sauver de cette façon elle va être bien
comme ça sur le côté c'est parfait ni
qu'elle avait la ramener comme ça à la
maison sinon il aurait fallu que j'aille
chercher la remorque
ça va aller beaucoup plus vite en
faisant ça en arrivant je la remettrai
dans un enclos je vais lui trouver un
agneau pour qu'elle puisse l'arrêter
parce que ça c'est un agneau plus âgés
celui là doit avoir dans les deux
semaines à nu le visage suis sûr que
c'est pas le froid qui a tué cet agneau
il était trop grand pour ça cette brebis
à plein de lait alors ça doit être un
truc comme vous dites vous savez la mort
subite du nourrisson du genre
elle a les mamelles plaines de l'est
alors c'est certain que je lui donnais
un autre agneaux à l'été on va pouvoir
laisser ce poulailler passer au prochain
je crois
je pense que la plupart des éleveurs ont
envie que les animaux qu'ils élèvent
soit en bonne santé ils veulent qu'il
s'épanouisse afin de faire un bon
produit un produit sain si certains sont
assez stupides pour mettre en danger la
santé de leurs troupeaux de leur cheptel
alors c'est vraiment tant pis pour eux
on a décidé d'élever les poulets en
plein air mais pour faire ça il vous
faut un terrain très étendue chaque ces
volatiles sont pires que des bulldozer
il vous ravages absolument tout sur leur
passage
il reste plus rien ce sont des
démolisseurs de première aujourd'hui
tous nos animaux sont élevés à
l'intérieur je crois sincèrement que les
gens enfin il que beaucoup de gens
aiment les animaux et qu'il est que
quelque part il pense que les animaux
résonne comme eux ils se disent des
trucs du genre à quoi pense est pauvre
vache toute la journée dans son état
alors qu'il est fort probable que les
vaches ça pense pas on dirait qu on
dirait qu'ils ont envie de donner aux
animaux ce que eux mêmes on sait ça
qu'ils aimeraient faire
voyez alors si un jour vous voyez une
chèvre conduire une voiture vous serez
qu'ils ont réussi du tout premier jour
où on a commencé à avoir des poulets on
avait déjà une idée très claire du
nombre de volatiles qu'on souhaitait
avoir dans cet endroit tout
particulièrement
on voulait qu'il puisse courir et faire
ce qu'ils avaient envie de faire
alors on est bien au dessous du nombre
d'animaux qu'on pourrait accueillir chez
nous on a 400 poulets dans chaque
poulailler mais si on voulait aller
jusqu'aux limites légales
on pourrait monter jusqu'à 1200
peut-être ouais c'est dingue
je pense que les gens ne se rendent pas
compte de la complexité qui lie à
produire de la nourriture dans notre
monde
l'une des particularités de l'élevage
porcin c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
saisonnalité dans notre production ont
produit la même quantité 52 semaines par
an et comme c'est une consommation
purement nationales nous sommes un assez
bon baromètre de la consommation de
viande de porc il ya noël qui est une
période spéciale de l'année pour nous
parce qu'il ya une forte demande en
jambon sur une seule et même journée les
vacances scolaires nous le savons dans
notre domaine les vacances scolaires
sont l'époque où les gens sortent plus
avec leurs enfants et ils vont plus dans
les fast-foods donc la demande baisse il
ya aussi une chose très spécial qui
affecte notre industrie est cette chose
c'est le loto
on ne peut pas vendre de porc lorsqu'il
y a des super cagnotte
parce que la demande en viande diminue
les priorités des consommateurs changent
il passe d'une demande de viande de
qualité à des produits moins coûteux
pour la semaine de la super cagnotte
lorsqu ils préfèrent acheter des tickets
de loto pour cette cagnotte et ensuite
il ya aussi l'effet boule de neige qui
se produit au fur et à mesure de
l'augmentation des super cagnotte 5,10
millions et plus l'engouement des
consommateurs pour le loto aux gones il
dépense 20 ou 30 $ de plus sur des
tickets de loto afin d'obtenir la vie de
rêve qu'ils ont toujours voulu avoir
c'est toujours un rêve inaccessible
parce que les chances de gagner sont
inexistantes alors le seul moyen pour
eux de nourrir leurs enfants
c'est ce même là c'est de leur dire on
va manger des trucs tout fait ou aller
au fast food cette semaine c'est ce
qu'il ya de moins cher pour nourrir des
enfants en fait connaissent rien d'autre
il ne mange pas un repas de qualité tous
les jours les gens pensent pas tous à
court terme
on s'en rend compte sur le long terme on
s'aperçoit que les gens consomment de
moins en moins de viande de qualité et
au final les habitants de ce pays se
porte moins bien on s'en rend compte en
termes d'obésité ainsi que dans tous les
indicateurs qui touche à la santé
allez les enfants voici votre nouvelle
maison
j'ai pas envie de passer le reste de ma
vie à travailler pour acquérir des biens
matériels
je préfère faire ce que j'ai envie je me
contente du minimum des choses de base
mais je dois avouer que je me fais du
souci pour mes enfants c'est surtout dû
au fait qu'aujourd'hui à l'orage il se
préoccupe surtout de jouer sur leurs
ordinateurs et leurs nouveaux jeux du
même acabit les encourage du mieux que
je peux à sortir de la maison et à
profiter de la nature
c'est super de pouvoir leur enseigner
les techniques de vie dans la nature le
respect pour les animaux les bases de la
chasse je voudrais leur faire comprendre
qu'on peut avoir une belle vie sans pour
autant posséder tous les derniers
gadgets en vogue mais chaque fois qu'on
va faire des courses
que ce soit dans les magasins de sport
ou au supermarché mes enfants ne
réclament à jouer je leur dis non je
veux bien t'acheter un outil ou une arme
mais je refuse de t'acheter un jouet je
trouve qu'il ya pas cette personne qui
chassent et qui se promène dans la
nature qui bêche sans fin qui font
toutes ces choses et qui serait capable
de transmettre leurs connaissances aux
futures générations
il y en a de moins en moins des gens
comme ça alors que leur nombre devrait
être en augmentation de plus en plus de
gens s'éloignent des connaissances les
plus basiques y en a de moins en moins
qui savent allumé un feu ils savent même
pas par où commencer
ils savent pas quel type de bois
utilisés ils savent comment utiliser un
briquet ou une boîte d'allumettes mais
c'est à peu près tout c'est ahurissant
de voir le nombre de gens qui sans avoir
recours à un produit inflammable sont
capables d'allumer un feu c'est ça la
nature humaine
pas vrai tout le monde va vers la
facilité personne ne veut se donner un
peu de mal pour obtenir des choses tout
ce qu'on fait c'est prend prendre
prendre ne donne rien en retour
mais le jour où les ressources
naturelles seront épuisés alors là
faudra bien trouver des alternatives
mais en attendant que ça arrive on va
continuer à conduire nos voitures pour
aller au boulot
continuer à acheter de la viande au
supermarché continue à faire des
barrages sur les rivières pour avoir de
l'énergie
l'ignorance une bénédiction pas vrai
[Musique]
non je dirais pas que c'est une femme
facile à entretenir l'élevage intensif
ce qui me concerne ce que j'essaye de
tirer le maximum de mes capacités pour
faire tourner mon affaire c'est vrai
qu'il faut y mettre beaucoup de travail
personnel
des tas de gens pensent qu'ils
travaillent beaucoup mais ce n'est pas
la réalité
en fait ils ne font que faire le strict
minimum même si je veux gagner de
l'argent avec ma ferme
il faut que j'en fasse le plus possible
ouais si fier de ce que je fais si on
fait pas bien son boulot autant rien
faire du tout
l'odeur de l'agneau c'est important la
brebis va reconnaître son petit grâce à
l'odeur de sa peau
alors on va mettre cette posture l'autre
agneaux dont on veut qu'elle s'occupe
fois la trompait et lui faire croire que
c'est 100 comme ça elle s'en occupera
beaucoup plus vite
une brebis plus âgés se laisserait pas
avoir elle est habituée mais quand il
s'agit d'une toute jeune brebis elle
connaît pas le truc
et quand il s'agit d'un agneau mort-né
comme c'est le cas ici elle pourra pas
faire la différence
ça va lui faire comme une sorte de
manteaux en plus en tout cas c'est comme
ça que mon père la plaie ils disaient
ils ont un manteau en plus c'est un peu
la même chose chez les humains quand un
gamin perd ses parents
quelqu'un d'autre l'adoptent c'est
pareil il y va de la survie de l'animal
j'enlève toute cette merde j'ai pas
envie de la mettre sur moi
on fait un peu comme on enfilerait un
pull un enfant c'est à peu près ça je
veux lui passer les deux pattes avant
les deux trous la seule différence que
la brebis va noter c'est que son agneau
et est de couleur blanche et que là
c'est un peu plus foncée mais quand elle
va sentir son odeur
elle devrait bien prendre la chose quand
elles sont plus vieilles
ça prend plus longtemps c'est plus
difficile de les tromper j'ai fait des
trous à l'arrière pourrait faire passer
les pattes
vas-y petit mais toi tu bouffes et le
voilà avec son nouveau plage prêt à
rencontrer sa maman d'adoption il reste
même là que de l'autre la peau est un
peu grande mais ça devrait le faire et
d'ici un jour ou deux elle va l'avoir
accepté et je pourrais lui enlever cette
peau elle croire axé son agneau ça va le
faire
je vais aller leur maître ils allaient
rencontrer sa nouvelle maman oui voici
la nouvelle maman
oui tu veux bien nuit où toi voilà une
petite bestiole qui était quasiment
morte il ya encore deux jours
enfin moi je croyais qu'il était mort
plus et trouver une maman de
substitution qui va nourrir et remplacer
celle qui l'a abandonnée est le plus
drôle de l'histoire dirais plutôt même
le plus ironique c'est que si elle ne
nourrit pas un agneau elle va finir à
l'abattoir
vous voyez ici ce n'est pas vraiment une
ferme avicole les poulets qui vous
acheter au supermarché ils peuvent
s'estimer heureux s'ils vivent cinq
semaines avant d'être abattu alors que
nos volailles sont élevées pour la ponte
les consommateurs chinois veulent des
volailles tuée alors qu'elle était sur
le point de pondre
c'est à dire quand elles ont environ 16
parfois dit cette semaine la viande que
vous obtenez alors à une texture
différente un peu différent que veulent
les consommateurs
ils doivent donc payer pour le temps
supplémentaire où je dois élever les
volailles pour qu'elles soient à leur
convenance ce qui signifie que c'est un
marché de niche
nous sommes satisfaits du volume que
nous obtenons et qui contribue à notre
survie financière
ils en veulent plus légalement nous
pourrions doubler le nombre de poulets
que nous produisons mais ce que nous
aurions à faire pour vendre plus de
volaille ne nous emballe pas leurs
conditions de vie serait terrible alors
nous produisons moins de poulet que nous
le pourrions mais nous sommes heureux de
ce que nous faisons
évidemment que nous voulons gagner de
l'argent mais nous ne voulons pas en
gagner coûte que coûte c'est sûr
m
[Musique]
e
m
je pense pas que l'animal mérite de
mourir parce que j'ai fait des
kilomètres de marche non c'est pas pour
ça c'est juste que si je devais aller au
supermarché pour chercher ma nourriture
et que le supermarché était à 10 km je
marcherai quand même je resterai pas
assis à mourir de faim eh ben c'est
pareil pour la nourriture qui sert à
alimenter ma famille ici il faut que je
fasse des kilomètres pour tuer l'animal
peu importe avec la chasse il ya
toujours un but
et moi ça me motive j'ai jamais trop
compris les alpinistes qui escaladent
les montagnes juste pour planter un
drapeau au sommet et ensuite ils
redescendent mois grimpe en haut des
montagnes
s'il ya du gibier à tuer c'est ça le but
de la chasse ouais c'est difficile à
réaliser comme but il faut bien à cinq
sorties de chasse infructueuses pour une
ou je vais avoir de la chance et parfois
c'est même plus que ça faut que j'aille
10 ou 12 fois la chasse avant de réussir
à tirer quelque chose
il s'agit pas seulement de se balader
dans la forêt en s'éloignant de la route
et de tirer sur un animal faut toujours
trouver des coins nouveau et découvrir
des endroits qui resteront secrets c'est
bien de faire ça parce que les animaux
change de coin suivant les époques de
l'année
en général je peux quasiment prévoir où
va se trouver un animal suivant la
période d'une année ce qui est plutôt
pratique car contre une rémunération des
gens peuvent venir tuer ces animaux à
gay est une certaine façon que je crois
que j'ai mis à la mode ce style de vie
[Musique]
26e ng permanent de défendre notre droit
a rélevé nos animaux on doit défendre ce
que l'on fait et comment on le fait
les gens nous disent assez cruel de les
élever pour ça et tout un tas d'autres
choses mais aucun de ces cochons ne
serait venu au monde si les gens ne
mangeait pas de porc alors il ya quelque
chose qui m'énerve c'est de voir qu'un
éleveur passe tellement de temps à
produire de la nourriture et après vous
lisez les articles sur les gaspillages
de la nourriture par les citadins qui
achètent des choses qu'ils jettent
ensuite on raconte qu'il ya jusqu'à 40 %
de la nourriture achetée qui est
gaspillée qui n'est pas consommée ce qui
en tant qu'éleveur est plutôt
démoralisant le produit environ 4500
port tous les halls a et donc à peu près
mille six cent d'entre eux qui ne sont
pas consommés c'est horrible pour moi de
savoir ça j'ai produit 1100 port pour
rien si 40% d'entre eux ont été foutu à
la poubelle l'impact que ça sur
l'environnement est extrêmement
important quand on pense à tous ces
camions qui transportent de la
nourriture qui n'apportera jamais aucun
apport nutritif à un être humain c'est
de la nourriture qui est complètement
gaspillé alors même si on est bien
conscient qu'une partie de ce gaspillage
va retourner dans la chaîne alimentaire
c'est quand même pas une façon très
intelligente de produire des cochons ça
aurait été plus malin de ne jamais les
faire venir au monde
je crois que j'aimerais voir les
consommateurs c'est à dire ceux qui
achètent notre production
peut-être plus respectueux de l'effort
qui a été fourni pour produire cette
nourriture pour eux et ceci à un prix
qui leur convient il faudrait qu'ils
réalisent que c'est comme ça que se
produisent des catastrophes
environnementales
lorsque nous devons su reproduire afin
que les consommateurs puissent gaspiller
si vous balancer une douzaine de
saucisses de porc c'est c'est autant que
je n'aurais pas eu à produire
regardez les c'est ma faute
les stress en restant dans la porcherie
c'est ma faute c'est ça les petits
commencent à se bagarrer pour se faire
une place dans le groupe
ce sont deux petits mâles qui veulent en
découdre non non ce sont des femelles
c'est encore pire elles se disent
bonjour à leur manière elles
j'ai jamais eu peur n'ont jamais n'a
jamais été à l'ordre du jour de quoi est
ce que j'aurais eu peur
vas-y pépère pouces vous savez quand
j'ai intégré la police en 1979
les flics est comme on nous appelait
alors on était tout juste bonne à faire
le café et à nous occuper des gamins bas
ils se sont mis le doigt dans l'oeil
jusqu'au coude
jusque là je m'étais pas vraiment rendu
compte que les femmes étaient traitées
différemment
il a fallu que j'intègre la police pour
le réaliser vraiment sans blagues salées
pas pouvoir le faire
faut dire que c'était un univers
totalement dominée par les hommes
il n'était pas très ouverts en ce qui
concerne les femmes j'avais un sergent
qui considérait que les femmes ne devait
pas se trouver dehors après 23 heures
il a fallu que ça change et rapidement
si j'avais pas été aussi volontaire
c'est sûr que je me serais fait marcher
dessus
je me souviens encore de mon supérieur
qui me disait il est 23 heures c'est bon
tu peux rentrer au poste plus disait non
à payer galles travail égal je voyais
alors se gratter la tête parce qu'il
n'avait jamais rencontré une femme qui
voulait aller à l'affrontement
moi j'étais toujours la première à
vouloir eagle
vous savez vous de là les mecs j'arrive
c'est comme ça et c'est tout j'ai pas
idée du nombre de délinquants que j'ai
bouclé quand j'étais à shannon j'ai bien
dû en arrêté 120 en une année quand j'ai
été affecté là bas personne ne voulait y
aller
pas même les mecs ils voulaient surtout
pas avoir affaire aux gens du voyage
parce que il n'hésitait pas à leur tirer
dessus
c'était pas évident mais j'ai gardé le
cap et j'y suis arrivé j'étais juste
avec tout le monde
peu importe à qui j'avais affaire
faisait aucune différence entre les gens
quelle que soit leur couleur leur race
ou leur niveau social
tout ça ça n'avait pas d'importance pour
moi je m'en moquais pas mal j'étais
correct avec tout le monde
ils savaient à quoi s'en tenir avec moi
c'est tout je dirais que depuis une
dizaine d'années les choses ont vraiment
changé
les femmes ont plus d'opportunités qui
s'offre à elle et ça c'est vrai dans le
monde entier alors je me fais plus trop
de soucis en ce qui concerne l'égalité
hommes femmes
je m'inquiète surtout pour les futures
générations ils savent franchement pas
se débrouiller pour faire les choses par
exemple quand je reçois deux jeunes
employés que je leur demande de me
réparer ou construire un trucs basiques
la plus barrée savent pas comment
utiliser un marteau et des clous j'ai
vraiment été médusés de constater ça moi
quand j'avais trois quatre ans et que je
me suis servi d'un marteau pour la
première fois et que je me suis tapé sur
les doigts
ça m'a servi de leçon mais quitte à
petit j'ai appris à faire gaffe ils ont
aucune idée pour quoi que ce soit en
fait ils sont trop habitués appuyer sur
une touche d'ordinateurs et à ce que
tout soit déjà pré mâchée ces nouveaux
systèmes sont mieux comme ça il saigne
pas on n'aura pas nettoyé
c'est mieux peut-être que demain matin
il faudra juste lui mettre un seau d'eau
fraîche sur la tête et ça pourra la
faire
allez nous élevions des volailles dans
une affaire précédente qui marchait
plutôt bien et puis un jour on nous a
averti qu'il allait falloir quand
s'automatise et ce qui signifiait que
des poulets allaient probablement avoir
la tête et les pattes tranché alors que
nous on les laissait alors on a pris le
taureau par les cornes et on a décidé de
monter notre propre abattoir
ce qui était un sacré truc et petit à
petit on est arrivé à en abattre 8 cents
par semaine
ouais c'est notre moyenne aujourd'hui un
gros abattoir en tue environ 95 milles
par jour
alors comme vous le voyez nous sommes un
peu plus modestes les cageots passe dans
cet appareil ou les volailles vont être
anesthésiés ensuite on l'aimé
inconsciente dans ces cônes tête la
première
leurs carottes idées tranchées et les
volailles sont saignés ensuite elles
sont placées dans ce bac où elles sont
et bouillante et puis elles vont être
plumés et diriger vers la zone
d'éviscération deux personnes sont
chargées de les vider de leurs
entrailles et ensuite ils les mettent
dans ce bac de réfrigération les
volailles sont ensuite pesé puis mise
sous emballage et on les vend le jeudi
matin
voilà c'est ça la réalité de la vie il
faut manger pour vivre
et le fait est que nous mangeons des
animaux alors quand il faut les tuer il
est impératif de le faire avec le plus
de bienveillance possible quand je suis
à la recherche de personnel j'aime bien
embaucher de jeunes retraités c'est
super vous parlez avec eux alors comment
ça se passe la retraite
oh c'est super c'est merveilleux d'être
à la retraite et vous fait quoi de vos
journées
j'aimerais bien me trouver une
occupation alors j'ai peut-être quelque
chose pour vous et du coup je les
embauches
les retraités ont de l'expérience
les femmes sont peu susceptibles de
tomber enceinte et il crève d'envié de
se trouver une occupation et en plus ils
sont pas contre un petit peu d'argent de
poche et j'ai constaté qu'ils étaient
plus fiables que des personnes plus
jeunes même si nous avons eu des jeunes
qui étaient d'excellents éléments mais
évidemment cela vous ne regardez pas
longtemps meilleurs ils sont et moins
longtemps il reste j'aperçus des animaux
aux diasporas il va patienter pour voir
ce qu'ils vont faire
je vous vois mes cocos
se sont arrêtés sur un piton rocheux
s'ils restent où ils sont ce serait
génial comme ça ils sont à portée du
geste à rester en bas de la colline
là où on aperçoit la neige il suffira à
près de progresser doucement et petit à
petit on arrivera jusqu'à
au parlement sera peut-être obligé de
remonter jusqu'au sommet
ils sont là bas sur le gros amas de
neige et nantes à j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils nous ont vus ils sont pas
stressés je vais me préparer au caire
c'est un système qui est bien rodé les
truies que nous isolons aujourd'hui
commenceront à s'accoupler vendredi
matin je vais commander plus de semences
aujourd'hui comme ça celles qui sont en
manque depuis aujourd'hui seront à point
pour vendredi matin et nous
recommencerons l'insémination
artificielle vendredi sa celles qui sont
abstinents aujourd'hui retourneront en
ahl lundi prochain vous est reparti pour
un tour
on a de quoi être bien occupé je ne
pense pas que l'argent soit ma seule
motivation je me suis organisé une
petite vie autour de cette activité et
l'argent est le résultat d'un système
qui tourne bien
j'ai pratiqué de nombreux sports et
l'argent c'est comme gagner la coupe
c'est l'ultime récompense que ce soit un
match de foot de 90 minutes ou un match
de rugby de 80 minutes
vous devez prendre des décisions qui
vont peser sur le fait que vous allez
gagner ou perdre la partie et c'est ce
qu'on fait tous les jours de l'année
dans notre entreprise
je dois mener notre société jusqu'au
succès et faire de mon mieux pour ça en
fait la motivation est identique il ya
de l'argent ou pas à l'appeler
finalement on s'aperçoit que c'est
exactement la même chose quand je
repense aux échecs que j'ai pu avoir je
m'aperçois que j'ai été encore plus
affectées lorsqu'il n'y avait pas
d'argent en jeu que lorsqu'il y en avait
la vie est un jeu et vous jouez pour
gagner
j'espère que je ne vais pas vous semblez
arrogant à vouloir toujours gagner mais
c'est quand même mieux d'essayer de
toujours finir dans le peloton de tête
non c'est donc une stratégie que
j'applique à ma ferme
si je m'occupe bien de mes bêtes ou si
je prévois les bonnes conditions météo
ou si gentil si bien les ventes le
résultat sera quand j'obtiendrai un
revenu plus important mais ce n'est pas
ça ma motivation première moi ce que je
veux c'est prendre les bonnes décisions
si je voulais gagner plus d'argent
il y aurait d'autres moyens plus
lucratif que de m'occuper d'une ferme
et tout ce qui se passe mal fait
toujours les gros titres des journaux
certaines personnes ne vois vraiment pas
plus loin que le bout de leur nez
en fait la raison pour laquelle leurs
coupons là que c'est que les moutons et
les agneaux peuvent être infesté par les
mouches à viande qui vont contre sur eux
on risque de provoquer des milliards qui
sont des infections occasionnés par la
présence dans le corps de l'arve paradis
alors il faut être super vigilant 115
parfois il me semble que la société se
porterait mieux si elle s'occupait mieux
de ces humains plutôt que d'essayer de
vouloir démontrer aux fermiers ce qu'il
devrait ou ne devrait pas faire arrêter
bien ordonnée commence par soi même et
je trouve que la société ferait bien de
s'occuper déjà d'elle je me dis parfois
que si on appliquer à l'ensemble de la
société les règles qu'on applique dans
une ferme on résoudrait bien des
problèmes
comme je voulais déjà dit tout à l'heure
quand on voit l'éducation que reçoivent
certains enfants de nos jours avec des
gens qui se droguent et qui picolent
alors qu'ils ont un bébé de seulement
quelques mois ne devraient plus avoir le
droit d' c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement répréhensible vous savez que
nous on traite mieux nos animaux que
certaines personnes traitent leurs
enfants en leur interdisant tout espoir
de s'en sortir dès le plus jeune âge la
moitié de ces incapables de parents
nourrissent leurs enfants avec de la
nourriture de mauvaise qualité
c'est pour ça qu'on a tellement de
problèmes d'obésité entre autres ces
pauvres gamins ne sont pas nourris avec
des aliments de qualité
il serait en meilleure santé s'ils
étaient mieux alimenter
[Musique]
quand vous vous occupez d'animaux il
faut que ces derniers puissent en
quelque sorte être sûr que vous ferez
tout ce qu'il faut pour qu'ils aillent
bien c'est pour ça que lorsque vous les
mettez dans les cages qui vont aller
dans le camion qui va les conduire à
l'abattoir vous trompez un peu la
confiance qu'ils ont en vous parce que
vous décidez de quelque chose qui ne les
emballe ray pas s'ils avaient leur mot à
dire quand vous discutez avec des gens
lors d'une soirée par exemple et qu'il
vous demande vous faites quoi dans la
vie
j'élève des volailles quel genre de
volaille bunge élève des poulets vous
êtes producteur 2 non je les élèves pour
leur viande
elles disent hors oui oui il me demande
pas comment vous faites pour les tuer la
plupart des gens veulent pas qu'on tue
des animaux mais pourtant ça les empêche
pas d'aller au supermarché acheter leurs
filets de poulet proprement emballé il
met une distance entre eux et ce moment
particulièrement déplaisants il ne voit
jamais l'animal vivant mais c'est la
nature humaine
vous savez on n'a pas envie de faire de
mal lorsqu'on rassemble les poulets pour
ce qui va se passer le lendemain matin
nous attendons qu'ils soient endormis on
met une lampe frontale
on saisit l'animal pour le mettre dans
la cage il se réveille à peine je suis
mal à l'aise quand je choisis les
animaux qui vont être tués
j'ai l'impression d'être un traître elle
était sympa ces pauvres bêtes
[Musique]
tony est venu me voir deux fois avant de
m'embaucher
il m'a dit je dirige un abattoir pour
les volailles et c'est un endroit où on
a voulu le plus d'humanité possible
quand ils gazent les poulets moi je suis
censé travailler aux différents postes
de la chaîne de production
c'est pas un travail très variés mais
j'imagine que c'est comme ça que ça doit
se passer
j'étais sûr qu'un jour je ferai ce
boulot j'ai accepté ce travail parce que
c'est du travail
j'ai toujours accepté toutes les
propositions d'emploi qu'on a fait c'est
vrai que c'est un boulot qui semble
horrible quand on arrive ici la première
fois et c'est vrai que je suis pas aussi
cynique que certains je vous dirai pas
qu'à chaque fois que je dois tuer un
pool et je pense aux pauvres bêtes je
vais te voir te tuer mais il est vrai
qu'à chaque fois que je mets des poulets
dans les cônes je me dis qu'il y en a
encore des dizaines d'autres qui vont
ils passer après c'est vrai que ça fait
quelque chose quand même
parfois j'ai des insomnies quand je
ferme les yeux je vois des seaux remplis
de tête de poulet et je dors plus de la
nuit
certains soirs j'ai du mal à aller me
coucher chacun des employés à sa façon
de gérer le truc bien gars que ça
chamboule aussi mais qui n'osent pas le
dire alors au lieu de l'avouer il arrête
pas de parler du poulet en disant qu'il
allait rappeler tissant il voudrait bien
le manger c'est super bon comme plat il
fait ça à chaque poule est qu'ils tuent
et c'est souvent quand il fait très
chaud et qu'il y a beaucoup de vapeur ou
quand ça sent particulièrement mauvais
qu'il se met à dire que ce poulet a
l'air super délicieux et qu'il aimerait
bien le dévorer je crois qu'il se
concentre sur le fait que c'est de la
bonne nourriture pour faire passer ce
mauvais moment
chacun d'entre nous a ses trucs je
reconnais que je ne mange plus autant de
viande qu'avant ça me tente moins
aujourd'hui
avant je pouvais dévorer un poulet
entier rien qu'à moi tout seul et
maintenant je le partage volontiers avec
toute ma famille lorsque je sais ce qui
est arrivé à cet animal avant qu'il soit
dans mon assiette
je trouve que les gens ne sont pas
censés voir comment on tue des animaux
mais je suis sûr qu'ils aspiraient moins
de viande
moins de produits animaliers et moins de
choses en général les choses qui cause
de la souffrance quand on les produits
gaspillerait - s'il avait dû affronter
la réalité
les animaux sont vivants et l'instant
d'après ils sont morts et c'est pas la
fin du monde pour autant ils ont été
élevés pour devenir un aliment alors on
peut se dire qu'il serait pas venu au
monde
si les gens ne mangeait pas après mais
tant qu'ils sont vivants
on doit leur apporter de la
considération je me suis pas fixé de
limites du genre après avoir tué cinq
mille poules et je démissionne parce que
si j'avais fait ça j'aurais qu'une envie
se serait de partir mais maintenant
quand j'y pense je me dis que pour moi
si si le fait de tuer ne perturbez pas
plus que ça si je devenais complètement
insensible à tout ça et que je me disais
c'est juste de la viande
alors là je partirai je démissionnerai
c'est super calme ici c'est le grand
silence
on se croirait dans un supermarché dans
un film d'horreur ou un truc du genre
n'est il n'y a personne aux alentours
tarifs via personnes allez je vais la
vie des je vais lui enlever ses boyaux
c'est très gratifiant de faire ça ouais
c'est gratifiant plus celle-là elle a
une fourrure superbe jeu mais bien lui
enlever il n'y a pas si longtemps
j'étais encore en train de me promener
dans la montagne je me baladais
tranquille voilà deux secondes après
dingue je les tuer
c'est le bazar là dedans
il a reçu une balle dans les poumons je
vérifie bien ses poumons pour voir s'il
aurait pas des nodules ou des lésions
qui pourrait indiquer qu'il avait la
tuberculose et apparemment il avait
l'air d'être en bonne santé
nous autres on mange pas les poumons on
est comme si ils font ce qu'on appelle
haggis avec moi je suis pas trop friand
des poumons et le coeur en revanche
c'est quelque chose de très bon ça c'est
son coeur justement c'est très bon à
manger le coeur
il paraît que c'est extrêmement bon pour
l'organisme
je vais le vider de tout le sang qui
reste assez chouette comme vision non
avant je travaillais comme frigoriste
dans un abattoir
c'était déprimant y avait l'odeur de la
mort qui régnait là dedans on sentait la
mort on entendait la mort c'était un
boulot vraiment super déprimant je les
fais pendant quatre mois peut-être après
je pouvais plus gagnais bien ma vie et
le boulot était pas inintéressant mais
c'était le fait d'évoluer dans cette
odeur de mort jour et nuit
ces terres c'était un peu déprimant
ça prend un peu de temps avant qu'on
s'habitue à tuer des animaux
au début ça m'attriste est je me
souviens du premier cercle que j'ai tué
j'avoue que j'ai versé quelques larmes
j'étais super triste c'était pareil la
première fois que j'ai tué à la fin
j'étais gamin j'arrêtais pas de chalet
aujourd'hui j'ai tellement tu es
d'animaux que je suis un peu habitué et
ça me fait plus grand chose
je suis pas triste c'est vrai que c'est
malheureux que l'animal ne puisse plus
se balader dans les montagnes mais le
fait que j'ai plein de nourriture à
rapporter à la maison l'emportent sur la
tristesse de la situation j'oublie
complètement que c'est un événement un
peu douloureux aujourd'hui nous allons
tuer les plus petits d'entre eux je vais
donner un peu de cela à mes cochons
certains d'entre eux vont en boire pour
la dernière fois comme je voulais déjà
dit je suis vite ému quand je regarde
des films avec des animaux on arrive
souvent de pleurer en les regardant je
suis bon public
je pleure un bon coup et puis je me
remets au travail ensuite je peux aller
tué un mouton ou un cochon après tout
quand on her est arrivé et en heure est
arrivée
si les gens voyaient les animaux morts
ils mangeraient plus de viande ça leur
serait insupportable
mais la mort fait partie de la vie il
n'y a que deux choses dont on soit
certain on est et on meurt c'est aussi
simple que ça auparavant j'avais envie
d'être bonnes avec les gens de faire le
bien dans ma communauté
mais aujourd'hui j'ai de grosses
responsabilités dans ma ferme
je veux me débarrasser de mes dettes
puis après ça j'aimerais voyager j'ai
envie de découvrir la nature comme le
grand canyon les villes ça m'intéresse
pas j'aimerais bien aussi aller au rodéo
de calgary au canada par exemple
mais d'un autre côté dans tous ces pays
lointains et la menace terroriste et
j'ai sûrement pas envie de disparaître
dans une explosion
si ça devait mal tourner et que je me
retrouve menacée à bord d'un avion une
chose est sûre c'est que je me laisserai
pas faire
je ferai tout pour rester en vie coûte
que coûte pas du genre à rester assise
dans le siège attendre que ça passe
j'espère vivre le plus longtemps
possible
je crois que la réponse c'est de rester
actif tu vas pouvoir lever
donc tu bouges tu fais des choses ça va
c'est quand tu restes assis dans son
canapé à glander tumeur alors il faut se
bouger ils retravailleraient toujours à
la ferme et je resterai toujours ici et
j'aurais jamais dans une maison de
retraite
je préférerais encore mourir tout
vous avez le droit un jour de ram et
pépère allez on y va
je ne pense jamais à ma vie en termes de
succès je fais ce qui me plaît
non je suis pas coincé dans un bureau
par hape en usine
je suis très heureux de la vie que je
mène je m'inquiète pas trop de
l'héritage que je vais laisser laissé un
bon souvenir c'est ça que j'aimerais
tout le reste ces matériels je voudrais
qu'on se souvienne de moi comme un bon
gars voyez quelqu'un qui ne disait pas
de mal des autres qui profitaient pas de
tous les gens que j'ai rencontrés
je voudrais qu'il se disant me qui tant
que ça a valu le coup de me croiser un
jour dans leur vie oui je crois que si
le but premier des gens dans l'existence
c'était d'être sympa avec les gens qu'il
rencontre on aurait sûrement plus besoin
des forces armées qu'elles soient de mer
de terre ou de l'air la police
disparaîtrait il n'y aurait plus que le
service des objets trouvés
je crois je crois que ce serait pas plus
mal comme ça
j'aimerais bien que ça arrive oui mais
c'est quand même un peu présomptueux de
penser que si tout se passait comme je
le souhaite ou ça irait mieux
je viens d'avoir 30 9 anges approche de
la quarantaine
j'ai choisi de faire ce qui me plaît
dans la vie ce qui me passionne
j'avais déjà pris cette décision il ya
belle lurette
je voulais pas participer à la foire
d'empoigné de cette existence où
l'argent mène le monde
j'ai fait beaucoup de sacrifices pour
avoir cette vie et j'avoue que je suis
parfois un peu soucieux de savoir où je
vais trouver l'argent pour rembourser
mes emprunts mais l'un dans l'autre je
m'en sors il paraît que l'argent est un
mal nécessaire
pourtant faut bien reconnaître que
parfois plus les gens en gagne et plus
ils en veulent encore et encore ce que
j'aimerais c'est ne plus avoir d'emprunt
à rembourser et d'avoir juste l'argent
qu'il faut pour me payer le strict
nécessaire
mais vous savez comment on est on veut
toujours avoir un nouveau banc de jardin
une salle de bains dernier cri avec une
douche à l'italienne c'est un cercle
vicieux parce que pour ça il faut
continuer à faire un job qui souvent
vous déplaît pour vous payer des trucs
des plus belles choses et après vous en
voulez encore des plus belles puis
encore plus belle
il faut toujours vous travaillez plus
pour les avoir et puis un jour vous êtes
vieux et vous avez plein de temps libre
et plein d'argent mais votre vie elle
est passée où moi je suis super heureux
de vivre ma petite vie et de faire ce
que j'ai envie d'être sur le fil du
rasoir financièrement mais de faire ce
qui me plaît parce que c'est ça qui est
important
quand je serai vieux je n'aurai pas de
lingots d'or mais j'aurai une bonne
histoire à raconter
franchement vu ce que j'attends de
l'existence y'a pas grand chose que je
ferais différemment si je pouvais
revenir en arrière quand je pars de chez
moi pour aller jusqu'à ma ferme
je lève la tête et je me dis tout ça
c'est à moi c'est moi qui l'ait bâti je
mérite d'avoir ce que j'ai c'est que
sont maintenant cinq mois et demi et
c'est l'heure pour eux de monter dans le
camion
ils ne se rendent pas compte de
l'endroit où ils vont ils sont un peu
comme les gamins qui sont contents de
prendre le bus mais qui n'apprécient pas
forcément d'aller à l'école
mais il aime quand même la balade en bus
ils trouvent ça sympa je ne sais pas si
un jour on n'arrivera plus à en souffrir
mais toujours est il qu'on finit par
accepter que chaque organisme vivant
doit mourir un certain stade ça fait
partie du processus naturel de la vie et
de la mort
ce camion et cette remorque qui
transportent des cochons vont donner 18
tonnes de viande destinée aux
consommateurs
je ne réfléchis pas trop à l'endroit où
ils vont quand ils partent d'ici mais je
sais pertinemment qu'en montant dans ce
camion ils font leur dernier voyage
quand le sec arrivera sur mon compte
d'ici quelques semaines sans sera déjà
fini pour eux
si on fait le compte dans toute ma vie
j'aurai produit entre 15 et 20 mille
tonnes de viande porcine
j'ai produit à cette viande pour nourrir
1 million de personnes pendant un an
alors j'ai de quoi être fier de moi ça
me plaît d'imaginer que je nourris la
prochaine génération d'éleveurs de porcs
c'est assez chouette de penser que vous
avez construit quelque chose que vos
enfants pourront peut être reprendre un
jour ça c'est la récompense ultime
j'imagine c'est l'apothéose de votre
existence savoir que vous avez construit
quelque chose que la génération suivante
continuera à faire grandir
je suis impatient que mes enfants
reviennent vivre au pays
la première chose qu'il ferait serait de
doubler la taille de l'exploitation
ce qui signifierait qu'il doublerait
également la production de 400 tonnes de
viande de porc par an il passerait à
huit cents tonnes ce qui veut dire qu'il
pourrait nourrir 40 mille personnes par
an les gens auront toujours envie de
manger des animaux
alors pourquoi ce ne serait pas nous qui
les produit rien
[Musique]
on
je
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
oh
[Musique]